Paramount are not just planning One Bad
Robot Star Trek movie they're planning
two and it's going to be a prequel
oh welcome to sidre your SciFi TV and
Movie Channel okay so it is being widely
reported um and deadline were the first
ones to report it that Paramount
Pictures are apparently planning two
Star Trek movies that will go straight
to cinema these are not the movies being
planned by secret hideout these don't
will be straight to Paramount plus so
this isn't section 31 and The Bard movie
it is something else something that is
being produced according to this article
by Bad Robot now they do have a fair few
details about this new movie so what is
the first film it's obviously going to
be the Star Trek 4 the Chris Pine film
that I've told you is bubbling in the
background I'm going to tell you what I
think about this and why I think this
article isn't what it seems by the way
in a minute but first of all I'll just
tell you what the rumor
is so according to this report it is
going to be a film that will be directed
by Toby Haynes he's the guy that did
andle and the script has been written by
Seth Graham Smith who is the guy that
did um Abraham Lincoln vampire Hunter
which is a film that is actually
underrated I actually quite like that
movie and the Lego Batman movie so hey
there you go um this film apparently is
going to be set decades before the
original JJ Abrams 2009 Star Trek movie
and will exist still within the celvin
timeline so here's my first issue if
it's going to be decades before the 2009
movie I assume they mean the events of
the bulk of the movie you know the
actual Chris Pine part of the movie
because the film starts decades before
that it starts with Chris henwood's
character Kirk's dad dying aboard the
Kelvin that's when the timelines split
so if it's still a Kelvin timeline movie
it's actually got to be set within that
time period between the start of the
film and the rest of the film now I know
I've been being a little bit pedantic
there but I mean be accurate that's one
of my big problems with JJ Abram Star
Trek is they're not accurate so when
they say it's set decades before the
events of the 2009 movie but it's still
within the Kelvin timeline that's what
they mean they've also called this An
Origin story that also fills me with
Terror so let's speculate a little bit
about what we think that might
mean so as I say it's got to be after
the destruction of the
Kelvin are we going to see a young Kirk
a young Spock Etc again maybe them going
through school that would be good no it
wouldn't it' be awful or is this going
to be the event of some other part of
Star Trek now I would hope it would be
the event of some other part of Star
Trek because that would make sense it's
a big universe after all it's a big
Galaxy there are plenty of other stories
to tell but will they well I doubt it
because let's look at the evidence it
seems that every time anything is new
with Star Trek and particularly in the
new Trek they have to try and tag it
back to Kirk and Spark and everyone else
they did it with Discovery they did it
with obviously strange new
worlds so the evidence suggests they
will try and tag it back to the origins
of the Enterprise again where they'll
within the Kelvin timeline maybe we'll
see a bit more Pike but again that's not
decades before that would have to be
when Kirk and Spark Etc were kids so if
that is where they're going with this
and this is going to be a Star Trek in
Primary School thing that is going to be
awful I I I I would really struggle to
even get excited to watch it but we
don't know that's what they're planning
that is just pure speculation and based
on what they've done previously this
could be something that is going to
build up towards something else within
the Star Trek universe so how confident
am I low my confidence in this is low
but do I even think this is going to
happen well I know and I've told you
guys several times that there are
different voices of Paramount global at
the moment about Star Trek and there are
very high up Executives according to a
source that I speak to that actually is
linked to Paramount there are very high
up Executives at powermount Global that
think Star Trek in the TV Universe alone
what secret hideout is producing is too
complicated there are too many different
timelines going on there's jumping into
history and for the Casual viewer which
according to their demographics accounts
for about a third of all the Star Trek
viewers so these are people that just
jump in and out of Star Trek don't
necess necessarily watch it week in week
out wouldn't consider themselves to be
trekkies it's confusing for that third
and it disengages them it harms the
franchise because they can watch one
show then watch another show and not
have any clue what's going on because
they're in completely different you know
500 years apart sort of thing but then
you've got the animated stuff which is
also in slightly different timelines
even though it's more in line with sort
of original Tre you know the BR Tre sort
of thing so it is confus using for the
Casual viewer who just want to come in
and out of the who want to just watch it
every so
often that isn't an issue for me but
when it accounts for a third of your
viewers it is an issue for executives
that write checks over at Paramount now
it was these Executives that were
arguing against Star Trek 4 and what
basically killed it last time when it
was announced uh a year 18 months ago um
uh when that announcement came out that
surprised all the actors because Chris
Pine Etc didn't know that they were
doing it
and they're the people that have really
put the um Motion Picture idea on the
back burner with Bad Robot there is also
though another problem Bad Robot does
actually have an exclusivity deal with
Warner Brothers at the moment they
cannot do anything without Warner
Brothers permission now it does seem
that they are allowed to do other things
but only if Warner Brothers say they can
so when they sign this deal in 2009 they
were allowed to complete certain
projects like Star Wars Etc that was
written into the contract but Bad Robot
have not actually managed to produce
anything really for Warner Brothers in
the five years since they sign this deal
they've produced no major television
shows and no major movies they've been
involved in a couple of projects but not
actually produced anything now it's not
totally their fault there was a little
thing called covid and then a little
thing called nearly a Year's worth of
strikes but still in a 5year period
Warner Brothers have given them 20 $50
million and had no return now apparently
that deal was actually a five-year deal
so it will run out this August now that
is important and I'm going to come back
to it in a second so they have this
exclusivity deal so why would Bad Robot
even be talking to Paramount at the
moment unless theyve got permission from
Warner Brothers which they might have
well it does seem actually that JJ
Abrams is allowed to work independently
from Bad Robot so when actually Star
Trek 4 was announced a little while ago
it would have been secret hideout
producing it and JJ Abrams just attached
as a producer now this is not what this
article is saying this article is saying
that this movie will be produced by Bad
Robot so why I don't think this leak to
deadline has come from Paramount I think
this leak has come from Bad Robot as I
say the people I speak to who actually
do have really good connections over at
Paramount are telling me there is very
little interest in a movie that would go
straight to cinema right now they are
working with secret hideout they have a
plan over the next five years and that
is the plan they're pushing they do not
even though the Star Trek 4 has not
actually been
cancelled there are no major plans to
run with it at the moment but Bad Robot
has an exclusivity deal with Warner
Brothers that ends in around seven
months so for me this sounds like this
is a Bad Robot not a Paramount plan
Paramount Global I've not shut the door
on this completely so I think Bad Robot
are leaking this information because
they're trying to kick that door in they
want to produce two Star Trek movies
they are even going as far as preparing
scripts and lining up directors and that
the idea is to convince Paramount to do
it I think they are meeting some
resistance definitely from at least some
parts of the executive board and this is
their way of trying to leverage the deal
a little bit as soon as their deal with
Warner Brothers is done they need to
start picking up all the projects and
this might be their way they are
desperately hoping not just to get
another Star Trek four with Chris Pine
Etc they're hoping to get this prequel
movie as well I think JJ Abrams and Bad
Robot though are going to have a small
problem Paramount are not going to be
taking any major risks in the next you
know 12 months or so they're not going
to sign on 150 million $300 million to
invest in two Star Trek movies
particularly after Star Trek Beyond did
so badly they are really going to have
to have a unanimous support from
Executives high up at Paramount to get
this agreed this is not the sort of
project considering Paramount's current
business problems that Paramount are
going to sign off on in my
opinion when Paramount and its potential
merger with Warner Brothers actually
goes through then maybe that would be a
different thing and let's be honest here
this deal Bad Robot may be actually
raising this because of the close
relationship between Paramount and
Warner Brothers and the hope that maybe
that is how this will get made their
exclusivity deal won't matter then if
Warner Brothers are actually
co-producing it but that is not the case
right now and that is a long way off
potentially this merger with Warner
Brothers is going to take a long time to
happen even if it ever does it's got to
go through things like the FTC to get
approved and that is not a foregone
conclusion there are also potentially
other interested parties like apple who
would be very interested in maybe buying
the studio element of Paramount at very
least so my point here is the Paramount
don't know what the next 12 months is
going to look like and they're going to
be a little bit risk averse during that
period and new Star Trek movie straight
to cinema with Bad Robot is a risk now
you guys know me I am not a hate clicker
I don't do videos saying this is going
to be awful and this is going to be
rubbish I try to have an honest Channel
I try to be honest about my opinions I
don't worry about clicks too much I
worry about being you know honest so if
I tell you I have concerns about this
it's because it's genuine and to be
honest a lot lot of people are going to
share those opinions so if you're
positive about this that's great I'm
really hoping that you love whatever is
produced if ever happens but look at the
other comments trekkies are going to be
probably quite divided on this plan but
saying that get into the comments and
tell me what you think because this is a
community and what we all think is what
matters not just what I say so get into
the comments and tell me exactly what
you think about this idea a prequel Star
Trek with within the celvin timeline how
would that even work and where would it
be set what would it be about dear God
that makes me just I just no I I just
hate that idea but we need more details
let's wait and see what they're actually
planning first before we widely condemn
it and the Star Trek 4 movie do you ever
think it's going to happen because I'm
not convinced get into the comments and
tell me exactly what you think don't
forget that most of our new videos do
actually Premier on patreon first so go
over to
patreon.com you can watch it without the
adverts and for a small contribution
that supports the channel you even get a
free gift can't argue with that don't
forget to like subscribe hit the Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
and also go to
s.co our dedicated website and we do
articles based on most of our videos so
we try to add a little bit more
information for you to digest go check
it out as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next
time
[Music]